and welcome back to Hannity we're
reporting from Las Vegas tonight
yesterday President Trump the First Lady
Melania Trump they flew to Vegas and
they met with the victims of this
Massacre one of the survivors that they
spoke to was Thomas Gunderson Thomas was
shot in the leg on Sunday night but
despite his injury Thomas made sure he
got out of bed to greet the president he
explained this on Facebook he said I
will never lie down when the president
of this great country comes to shake my
hand there may be plenty of vicious in
this country but I will always respect
my country my president my flag and shot
in the leg or not I will stand to show
my president the respect he deserves
earlier today we did in fact have the
honor to go to University Medical Center
in Southern Nevada
we spoke with Thomas Gunderson watch
this how are you doing well I know I'm
not the president I apologize how you
doing I'm doing all right
can you believe the president comes here
yesterday first of all we believe what
happened I'm very very sorry
how you feeling honestly I'm okay I mean
can't quiet walk yet but I'm gonna get
there it was it was it the President or
the first lady that got you to walk I
was the first lady I've been honest no
no you know I had to I told my family
I'd present United States comes in this
room no matter who the president is you
stand up and you shake their hand and
show them the respect that they deserve
you know that's all it's a little hard
when you were shot in the leg
I mean wasn't easy but it was it wasn't
like I stood the whole time you know I
just wanted to show them respect you
know what that went viral and I agree
with you a hundred percent let's talk a
little bit about it so you having fun I
love country music to sob yeah
you're at the concert yeah and you you
remember obviously what happened where
were you go ahead
I remember everything but when it first
started going off it was like everybody
thought it was fake or not I shouldn't
say fake it sounded like it was the
speaker's malfunction or or maybe
somebody's setting off firecrackers I
mean even Jason Aldean played for
another 15 20 seconds the moment he
started to run
you God started screaming and then
that's when I
I realize kind of was going on where
were you in relation to the stage I was
uh pretty far I mean I was on the east
side of the stage maybe a hundred turn
feedback there's a lot of railings and
bars and stuff like that in between so
that's what he got hit no I didn't get
hit till I was probably one of the last
people to get hit I've spent the entire
20 minutes in there
my I mean listen I think everybody in
there in their own writers is a hero you
know they did what they had to do and I
hear more and more stories I mean of
amazing things people did honestly
amazing things people did so yeah we did
that and then at that point you know it
was like I said it was about the end of
it it seemed not that it was over but
almost everybody was kind of out of
there and the rounds were still going
off and we weren't seeing we weren't
seeing any gunshots and I think our
minds were so just focused on getting
people out or or finding him that we
didn't really see the bodies around us
and we looked at each other we said oh
it's it's fake somebody's messing with
us about 10 of us said that and so I
stood I stood out in the old room people
you knew just not use mad people all
just that were looking at to help you
know and at that point I hadn't looked
behind me I I saw a gunfire coming from
the hotel and that was perfectly just
lined up or flashes that's to say that
was just perfectly lined up with he
thought from about that floor no I
thought it was a completely different
floor lower I could have sworn that it
was centered the hotel about 15 floors
not more hey it could have been the
reflection you know the way that's the
way that is said it was and right then
and there
my mind was like oh and boom shot
through the lake most people want to
experience that what does that feel like
I I can't tell what everybody else felt
for me I didn't feel it I didn't I knew
I was shot but my body took over and um
I hit the ground and there was just just
blood everywhere
mm-hmm you know I know for me I didn't
really feel it your adrenaline is just
going nuts
talk about your injury and your
prognosis I honestly I'm so blessed and
went straight through the calf I didn't
hit an artery or or bone the nerves the
muscles are pretty torn up so I can't I
can't lift my foot to 90 degrees yet and
you did lift your foot for Melania Trump
what foot wouldn't I'm getting this tape
to the press so the president walks in
yeah first lady walks in to see you NORs
I like um very surreal very just
honoring honestly I mean I heard that he
just flew in for from Puerto Rico who
literally just came from there
I don't care what anybody has to say to
me Manny he he cared he wanted to listen
to me and shake my hand and thanked me
and and just was so awesome and Melania
was so sweet and to me it felt like they
genuinely cared about the people here
and and what happened I can tell you the
whole country is praying for you and for
all these other families there's some
families that lost their loved ones
others in this hospital this is a severe
injury there are worse injuries there's
a I'm so blessed to see I got off easy
and if that's the one thing like the one
message I could send to people is find
find the people who lost loved ones and
just love on them and show them support
because they're gonna need it I got off
easy and but there's a lot of positivity
going around and I hope people can focus
on that because I've seen an incredible
amount of love you know say my way it's
hard as this is like life-changing feel
this is this is a moment where you never
gonna be the same it's true and I'm
trying to do my best to use this this
stage to give a good message it's not
about Fame and I want people to know
that I I happen to be in this hospital
happen to be able to meet the president
there's you know it's really good for
America but I just want to say this to
you when you hear that somebody said oh
I got my friends to safety
let me help other people that shows how
great we are you know this country is
great and people like you make it great
because you put other people out of
yourself everybody in there was great on
everybody everybody did what they had to
do and everybody responded in the way
they needed to respond and everybody
should feel honored for the what they
did you know we played
about an hour before Jason got onstage
Big & Rich aradhna
the friends would both of them John Rich
more for many years yeah everybody had
the cell phone up I'll show you the
video if you haven't seen it's
unbelievable yeah and how a lady you
think this happens like everyone's
together then you got a big political
fight in the country and everyone's you
know does that bother you when you see
that no I'm not gonna give in to that I
can tell you I mean obviously my video
has has gone viral and there's a lot of
comments and probably eighty ninety
percent are beautiful comments and
support and I appreciate it so much and
there are some just horrific comments
and I'm reading every single one of them
and I'm not going to give in to that
sixty percent they get it it doesn't
always feel good but you know you
respond in love and there's nothing they
can do with that you know meeting people
like you it inspires me to and it
reminds me of some of the military guys
I mean me you know I'm sure in the days
that you're gonna be laid up here a
little bit and you obviously getting
back on your feet
if not we'll call the first lady say
Milani but you know they go through all
this every day you know so it makes you
appreciate I know that the appreciate
first thing I did was text actually my
marine buddy ken Ken fook-la man he's uh
he's an awesome man and I first thing I
did was text him and just talked to him
and I mean he's gone through this
multiple times you know and I just
wanted to talk to him because there's no
one in the world I respect more than did
our military it's just I just don't
so the those are our heroes for sure and
they give us the freedom to go to these
concerts absolutely and I I feel special
I feel lucky because of that so it's
hard you know those are those are the
real heroes